quick reminder please remember that we
are trying to replace the lost YouTube
revenue due to the YouTube advertiser
boycott which has taken 40% of our shows
revenue overnight we have launched a
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
that's our immediate goal we've been
targeting we've been discussing the
ideas that lawmakers should maybe be
hesitant to confirm a Supreme Court
justice nominated by a president that
may or may not have colluded with a
foreign adversary to become president
that foreign power of course being
Russia senator Elizabeth Warren recently
tweeted senator from here in
Massachusetts Neil Gorsuch is up for a
lifetime appointment to the Supreme
Court from a president whose campaign is
under FBI investigation
now democratic Connecticut Senator
Richard Blumenthal
a member of the Genet Senate Judiciary
Committee said that he will not vote for
Supreme Court nominee Neil Gorsuch
because of what he is calling a quote
looming possible impeachment of Trump as
far as I know Pat this is the first real
direct reference to possible impeachment
of Trump from a senator that I'm aware
of anyway right the other Democrats seem
to be going down the road of contesting
Neel Gorsuch because of how the
Republicans treated Merrick garland yeah
or just on Neil Gorsuch his own merits
sure this is the first time we know of
connecting it to the Russia
investigation this affected Blumenthal's
vote at the Senate Judiciary Committee
committee's meeting earlier this week to
decide whether or not to send the
nomination to the full Senate it will
clearly affect his vote on Friday when
the nomination is put in front of the
entire Senate and Blumenthal wrote in an
editorial for a Connecticut newspaper
that quote the independence of our
judicial branch has never been more
threatened or more important the
possibility of a Supreme Court needing
to enforce a subpoena against the
President of the United States is far
from idle speculation it has happened
before in United States v Nixon
Blumenthal cited Republicans treatment
of Merrick garland last year as yet
another reason why he's voting against
the nomination as Pat mentioned there
that other Democratic senators have done
and rightly so as I've been saying since
Donald Trump has already filed for the
2020 election
we should actually consider the election
to have already started and therefore
say hey you know what we're in the
middle of an election Pat we can't just
confirm a Supreme Court justice in the
middle of an election now that is a
point that I like can I agree with and
and as we talked about yesterday
Democrats now have enough votes to
filibuster and block course such as
nomination confirmation rather this will
probably cause Republicans to use what's
known as the nuclear option which would
change the Supreme Court nominating
rules so that a filibuster would be
ineffective changing the requirement for
60 votes in the Senate to only a simple
majority of 51 votes Mitch McConnell and
Republicans are acting like the use of
the nuclear option would be the fault of
Democrats like hey listen Democrats are
gonna force us to change the rules they
refuse to schedule a hearing for a
nominee Merrick garland and that is way
worse than filibustering Republicans
cause this situation to begin with Pat
and now they're saying well this is just
the fault of the Democrats and
unfortunately because people have lives
and jobs many people are not
understanding that the the problem
Republicans are claiming to need to
solve is a problem they created and now
the Democrats have to respond in kind
there's no alternative and the problem
is honestly they're fighting a losing
effort because even though they're able
to filibuster and force the nuclear
option they're just gonna be able to
pass corset with a simple majority
filibustering is reasonable logically
given the circumstances half the
government is investigating Trump
Gorsuch holds some pretty backwards
principles and Merrick garland should
have been given a hearing but more than
likely producer pat vegan producer Pat
as he is increasingly known is right
this will probably end up being sort of
a futile effort but I still don't think
that that means Republicans Democrats
shouldn't do it I still think they
should the blame here is on Republicans
once again Republicans said hey it's
Obama's last year we'll wait for the
next president they threw out whatever
you would consider standard operating
procedure it is open game as I see it
here's what you can do in the audience
contact Richard Blumenthal and contact
your senators if you don't live in
Connecticut congratulate Blumenthal you
can call his office at 202
two two four two eight two three tell
amis doing the right thing but also tell
your senators you want them to join
Blumenthal and not only vote against the
nomination but vote against the changing
of the rules the so-called nuclear
option if you don't know who to call go
to who is my representative dot-com to
find the contact info for all of your
elected officials today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby
Parker recently did the right thing and
ditched advertising on right-wing
conspiracy website Breitbart pulling
their ads off and you can get the free
five-day home Tryon from Warby Parker
check out their glasses I use them when
I'm not wearing contact lenses I started
with the free at-home trial they send
you five pairs of glasses you see which
ones you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS